I mentioned the iPhone 5 okay well today  after months of anticipation Apple  introduced the new iPhone 5 everyone's  talking about it there it is it's a  thinner lighter has a ton of new  features here's the deal though it won't  go on sale for another two weeks  yeah but Apple was nice enough to loan  us one of the first iPhone five so we  could give you our audience a sneak peek  at that it's very cool this is a huge  exclusive yeah this is big this is  really neat our intern our intern Colton  has just came back now to our studio  from the Apple Store and do we have him  Alan I think Colton's coming there he is  he has the iPhone 5 he'll be here any  second what's these guys doing it  yeah and then  [Applause]